all right having a sort of recovered
from that wild interview let's look at a
couple of other things I did want to
just briefly go over uh some of the
assertions made by attendees at both of
the Trump rallies over the weekend
Saturday in Nevada and Sunday in Arizona
uh in Arizona there was a woman who said
something that it just sounds wrong to
say about a trump speech listen to this
okay and what brought you out to the
Trump rally today president Trump what
are you looking for people what are you
looking forward to see from here today
oh my gosh the unity and the healing and
just move on and we just have to heal as
a nation and come together again
and the truth we wanted
unity and healing and certainly truth
are not common occurrences common
features of a trump rally in fact I just
saw a list of at a recent rally there
were about 40 different people or
organizations that Donald Trump attacked
but it's interesting how you can really
see in it anything you want even if it's
not there one of the wackiest pre-rally
moments at the Arizona rally was a woman
doing oh man I don't even know how to
explain this doing some kind of speed
drawing of Jesus and the hosts saying
you know it is Sunday after all it's a
very spiritual moment yeah so is she
she's just living her element she's a
beautiful woman painting for a large
crowd of American Patriots and obviously
Christina it's a spiritual moment for
her as well on this on this Sunday on
this Sunday uh it's it's very spiritual
moment uh that she's having with us
right now and it's just beautiful
yeah so they uh the woman does seem to
be having some kind of an issue then
they that they interviewed a guy with a
Second Amendment God's guns and guts
shirt and this guy he tells a sort of
sad story of for some reason having lost
many friends recently also lost a lot of
friends because I'm a trump fan I don't
understand it but you know what we're
all for we're all in for yeah yeah you
know what we're going to pray for those
people who cannot open their eyes right
and find out how great Trump is for this
country and Kerry Lake and of course you
got the whole roster of some great
conservative Republicans represent the
state yes sir yeah okay got your second
amendment as well I love that God's gone
guts everything yeah
and you know what you got a cool haircut
I'm hoping yeah
um I don't know if the guy is serious I
mean it's a interesting haircut
nonetheless but
um just really it's perplexing how could
this guy possibly have lost any friends
and you know what really strikes me
about these interviews is you know
imagine you go up to a guy like this and
you say hey you know what the tariffs on
China were actually not good
uh for the United States and we imagine
they go oh you know what that yeah
that's true that makes sense
these are folks that are so deep down
the rabbit hole that it just simply It
seems impossible it seems impossible
another guy now going to the Nevada
rally the previous day
a guy at the Nevada rally had an
incredible conspiracy theory about
what's happening in Ukraine listen to
this
and the thing that really makes me mad
about Ukraine we put the bio weapon Labs
under Obama and Obama said oh yeah we'll
give it give up the nukes and we got
your back we help cause this with
Ukraine under Obama
so I understand why Russia is in there
doing what they're doing with the whole
denotification of the Don boss region
because so many Ukrainian nationalists
uh seem to be full-blown Nazis these
days a lot of the media I've seen come
out of the Russians taking PW these guys
got swastikas all over them tattooed and
I'm like oh our media doesn't like to
play that though it's really interesting
how that works yeah you know we've
talked about this there is a there's a
small Nazi presence in Ukraine but this
is just a completely whacked conspiracy
theory Obama's really responsible
because he built bio labs in Ukraine and
made Russia give up nukes and so that's
what I mean it's just unhinged and it's
so it's wound up so tight that I don't
know how you undo it here's another
woman at the Trump rally who says she
loves Putin and it's sort of like not
exactly the message that I think they're
trying to associate with their movement
but it is what it is and
with Russia and
and I love Putin but I love Putin Putin
is making the right you know but the the
American people is built over there he
wants to clean them out you know
clean them out all the the the
biochemical Place everything and a
nuclear thing yeah we'll have to talk
more about this because
the president you know number two of the
president one number two yeah I mean
listen this is these are the these
people gravitate towards
authoritarian autocrats and so they
really do see
Trump and Putin or poutine
as similar and it's not exactly the
message that right side broadcasting and
all these different networks want to
want to put out there and portray uh but
it is accurate it is it is what it is
um here's just one last one this one's
from the also the Nevada rally here's a
woman who just talks again about all the
things she likes about Trump and none of
them are true I'd love him and I think
he's he's the kindest gentlest man he
listens and he's not a bully like they
tried it you know and he's mean but he's
absolutely I mean just look at his
children they don't smoke they don't
drink president Trump I mean he did
something right so there's a perspective
and I guess maybe the most false claim
in there is
um he's not a bully I mean it's hard to
think of a bigger bully so uh
are these folks Beyond reach is it
Beyond repair is are they too far gone
um let me know what you think and then
we will follow up it's the Perpetual
question as at least as far as it
affects elections we care about it